what's the role of the parents in this
picture
let's go to another difficult subject
yeah that is a difficult subject um
one study found that
um
the amount of maths anxiety parents had
predicted their child's achievement in
school
but
only if they helped with homework
so
that's so funny yeah
but there are some interesting
implications for this i mean you can see
how it works if you have maths anxiety
and you're helping your kids with
homework you're probably communicating
things like i was terrible at this at
school and
and that's how it gets passed on to kids
so
one implication is if you have a really
bad relationship with maths you hate
maths you have mass anxiety just don't
don't do math same with your kids
um
but we have a on our website we have a
little
sheet for parents of
ways to interact around maths with your
kids
and
that's uh
youcubed.org that's youcubed.org yes
so one of the things i say to parents
when i give parent presentations is even
if you hate maths you need to just fake
it with your kids you should be always
endlessly optimistic and happy about
doing maths
and um
i'm always curious about this so i you
know
i hope to have kids one day i don't have
kids currently
um are parents okay with like sucking at
math
and then
trying to get their kid to be better
than them essentially like is that
difficult thing for a lot of parents it
is difficult to have like it's almost
like an ego thing like i never got
good at this and i probably should have
and
yeah i mean to me this you want to
celebrate that but i know a lot of
people struggle with that like coaches
in sports
to to make an athlete
become better than them it can be hard
on the ego yeah
so yeah do you experience the same with
parents too i think i mean i haven't
experienced parents worrying that their
kids will be better than them
i have experienced
just having a really bad relationship
with maths and you know not wanting to
help not knowing how to help
saying things
like another study showed that when
mothers say to their daughters i was bad
at maths in school their daughter's
achievement goes down
so we know that kids pick up on these
messages
and
which is why i say you should fake it
but also i know that lots of people have
just had a really bad relationship with
maths even successful people like the
undergrads i teach at stanford have
pretty much always done well in maths
but they come to stanford thinking maths
is a set of methods to memorize
and so
so do many parents believe that there's
one method that you memorize
and then you reproduce it
so until people have really had an
experience of what i think of as the
other maths where until they've really
seen that it's a really different
subject
it's hard for them to be able to shift
their kids to see it differently
you